okay it's been a couple weeks let's do
some book recommendations backstory on
this segment I used to do these weekly
the segments did terribly on YouTube we
stopped doing them but due to popular
demand people said David please bring
back the book recommendation so I'm
doing this like every two to three weeks
I will remind you and this is what
hopefully will make this worthwhile to
continue doing if you go to david
pakman.com slash recommendations you
will find all of these recommendations
and others with amazon links where if
you buy them through the links at david
pakman.com slash recommendations we get
a slice like andrew yang likes to say a
slice of an amazon transaction we get a
slice of your amazon transaction if you
use the links at david pakman.com slash
recommendations to buy these books i've
got two non-fiction books here and two
fiction books let's get right into it
first one nonfiction life 3.0 by max
tegmark this is a great book about
artificial intelligence I believe that
it was Bill Gates who had recommended
this one at least put it on my radar
very very good because it is not
hyperbolic this book life 3.0 will take
all of the different fears and
hypotheses around the development of
artificial intelligence and it will sort
of like simmer down and speak in much
more measured ways about the risks and
the possibilities of artificial
intelligence I highly recommend it
it has some parts in it that you can
sort of skip depending on your knowledge
of technology I just read the entire
thing but definitely don't miss this one
life 3.0 by Max tegmark second
non-fiction book today this one I read
about a year ago
this is called traffic by Tom Vanderbilt
this is a book about traffic on the
roads and it will explain to you their
so traffic is interesting because the
the concept of traffic is interesting
because there are like mathematical
elements to understanding why is it that
we're going so slowly if there's no
crash like what what's causing this slow
I don't understand that what is the most
efficient means of merging when there is
a merge there are a lot a lot of
mathematical considerations around
traffic but there's also a lot of
sociology and culture around how highway
systems are designed in different
countries there are probably other
examples that I'm forgetting here this
book discusses a lot of that traffic why
we drive the way we do and what it says
about us by Tom Vanderbilt get it enjoy
it if you don't drive you will certainly
and get pleasure out of taking public
transit after reading this book for sure
let's now do two fiction recommendations
all right now this one I was very
hesitant to so III in general I'm kind
of hesitant often to jump into authors
that do like the massive bestsellers
that sometimes feel sort of like they're
for the lowest common denominator and I
don't say that at any kind of I don't
know pejorative way but like I've never
read a Stephen King book up until a few
months ago I just kind of resisted the
craze around it whatever this book is
really worth reading it's a big one it
is 21 on new york 21 40 by Kim Stanley
Robinson I've read nothing else by Kim
Stanley Robinson in my life this was
thoroughly enjoyable without passing any
judgment of any kind on any other work
by Robinson this is a great book because
it combines great readability
interesting characters with the issue of
climate change climate destabilization
rising sea level and a lot of the stuff
that we're dealing with today I don't
know that I need to say much more about
it but if you're into sci-fi if you're
into climate change dystopian sort of
stuff this is a great book it is about
600 pages it goes quickly it really is a
quick read as quick as 600 pages can be
and lastly this was recommended to me by
writer Elliot pepper who I will
sometimes trade recommendations with and
whose books I recommended
or it is called Avogadro Corp or
Avogadro corporation is what it stands
for
Avogadro's in the book this is by
William Hertling this is a placeholder
for a sort of massive multinational
could be Google like could be Apple like
you know that type of company and it is
let's see how much do I want to say
about it let's just say that it takes
you know how Gmail now has this feature
where it has predictive text if you have
it turned on as you're writing it will
consider what it is likely you are going
to write and let you autofill it will
say oh you're probably if you start
saying let's figure out tomorrow whether
we can increase it might add in the
prices if it knows that you're often
talking about increasing or decreasing
prices or whatever the book jumps off
from the idea of a more advanced version
of that Gmail feature that doesn't do
predictive text on the basis of what it
thinks you are likely to want to say but
it actually can restructure emails on
the basis of who the recipient is to
make them more influential when the
recipient gets that email so I might
write a sales email and the function
might say oh based on who it's going to
here's how that email could be rewritten
to make it more likely that you're gonna
make a sale that's the idea and it
expands from there and to the problems
that come from that really really good
it's actually kind of good to pair this
as a fiction book with life 3.0 by max
tegmark so check these out all of these
and many more recommendations available
at david pakman.com slash
recommendations any links you use on
that page to buy these or other ebooks
we will get a slice of those Amazon
purchases which is a really really great
thing and I appreciate everybody who is
already doing that